Aw yeah! Because you asked for it today we're
learning English with the Korean Pop band Black
Pink. So we will learn English with two of their
most popular songs plus a clip of an interview
they had on Jimmy Kimmel Live but before we get
into any of that I want to let you know that if
you are new here every single week we teach you
with your favorite movies, TV series, songs and
so much more so that you can understand fast
speaking natives without getting lost, without
missing the jokes and without subtitles. Just like
our fan Jatendra who says that thanks to our art
lessons he's improving his listening and even his
American accent. You will too. It's really simple
just hit that subscribe button and the bell down
below and you won't miss a single one of our new
lessons. Alright so now let's start with the
first song, Ice Cream featuring Selena Gomez.
So do you want to continue learning with the
song? Then head over to our Instagram and look for
this post where you can learn with the next part.
Now let's learn with the next song Lovesick.
By the way your ability to comprehend
connected speech is going to make a huge
difference in whether or not you're able to
understand natives even when we speak really fast
and this is exactly why it is a fundamental
part of our Fluent with Friends Course.
Now you can try that course absolutely free with
our Three Part Master Class where we will help
you to master pronunciation just like this in
addition to vocabulary and cultural context so
you can understand and laugh with the jokes. So
if you want to learn more about that and sign up
absolutely free it's really simple click
up here or down the description below
So we made this lesson talking all about
discourse markers and why they are so
important for sounding more like a native
so I highly recommend that you check that
out after you finish this lesson with Blackpink by
hitting up here or down in the description below.